bienvenue à paroles autochtone cissé
mais sa mort lundi puis cette semaine je
n'ai pas de question parce que c'est une
semaine particulièrement agréable pour
moi c'est la semaine du 21 juin
la semaine du solstice mais aussi la
semaine des cultures autochtones au
québec et au canada
donc je voulais profiter un peu pour
vous dire comment depuis quelques années
j'ai vu une transformation du narratif
je viserai de cette semaine si avant on
était beaucoup obligé de convaincre les
gens de s'intéresser à la culture des
premières nations est maintenant de plus
en plus la culture générale s'y
intéresse on voit que cette année en
2009 c'est la langue c'est l'année
internationale des langues autochtones
juste dernièrement innu nikamu chanter
la résistance a gagné l'iris du meilleur
documentaire québécois donc pas le
premier meilleur documentaire autochtone
le meilleur documentaire québécois donc
de plus en plus la culture
les premières nations commencent à are
et infuser justement la culture générale
et je trouve que c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement positif et que je veux
continuer à encourager parce que c'est
c'est triste à dire mais un grand pan de
l'histoire de la culture des premières
nations qui n'est pas par an au
quotidien mais de plus en plus de gens
et pas juste une programmation mais des
alliés ou s'ils travaillent très fort à
faire revenir cette culture-là de
l'avant et à la valoriser donc n'hésitez
pas à regarder autour de vous quel
événement va se produire
ils n'étaient pas même vous intéresser à
des auteurs à des musiciens des
premières nations
il ya énormément d'activités qui se
passe
à ce moment et puis quand on parle d une
unique amour justement peut-être que
vous allez avoir envie de faire le
voyage jusqu'à malioténam pour visiter
et profiter de ce festival de musique
est un des plus grands en amérique du
nord pour ce qui est de la musique
autochtone mais je peux vous dire que
pour moi c'est une année pour célébrer
parce que je vois vraiment une
transformation depuis avant un bon
moment depuis la crise d'oka en 1990
donc on continue c'est vraiment par les
changes entre citoyens qu'on va voir
cette réconciliation à paraître c'est
une belle semaine je souhaite un très
beau 21 juin